The joe rogan experience.
Thank you to whoever gave me this this weekend at the Ice House.
Some dude gave me hunter s Thompson is the rum diary on nice paper back.
Just one of the things that God did,
his share of drugs,
psychedelics.
Have you done your share yet?
No,
not yet.
As much as I took a four hour shower on mushrooms once.
Nice.
And then I was hiking in big whiskey mountain on mushrooms with my buddy.
We decided to take a back route,
which you never do.
I was climbing up a landslide.
That's smart and I was like to my buddy,
I go,
dude.
He goes,
what?
I go,
you got to move with the mountain.
You're not moving with the mountain.
He's like,
okay.
He's a real mountain mine.
So he's climbing.
I go,
it's done.
I'm over in the mountain.
Okay,
I'm going to stay here and talk to this rock.
And I had to have a conversation with a rock and then as he tells it,
we're on top of whisky mountain,
which is a very big mountain.
Okay.
Luckily it was in the summer as well.
I was with,
I was dating patty back in the day and they were waiting downstairs and he turns
back around and I'm not wearing any clothes and I mean,
no clue.
And I'm up on top of a mountain that,
that takes like a really long time to climb up.
And I'm naked.
What'd you do with the clothes?
We never found my clothes.
No,
but I did stop and need a lot of blueberries.
And by the time we asked,
took a,
she had squatting and then as I was doing that naked,
my buddy moved some branches pretending it was a bear jumped up and started to
run and uh,
that caused a problem.
And then I came back down the mountain,
all scratched up,
no quotes and I can stop and eat blueberries.
My buddy who got you stop eating blueberries.
I had a blue mouth,
a shit.
You walked,
you walked barefoot.
That's right.
My food.
I'll cut up my going to take,
I don't know,
a day and a,
I literally,
literally,
literally probably four hours or something,
like a five hour.
We're up at any point in,
during the war.
When I finally got down,
I had a blue mouth from eating blueberries and,
and I was all cut up and patty was like,
what are you doing?
I was like,
I need to did my ass in the lake.
I've shit ass cause I didn't have,
I couldn't walk,
wipe it.
So,
uh,
yet another one of my shit stories.
Thank you.
So,
so she was like,
wow,
that's attractive.
You're a,
you're my man.
Well I'll take the skinny guy with the blue mouth and a shit in his ass.
It was coming down off mushrooms.
So that was my experience with marsh.
How much did you take?
Did I heat?
My buddy gave me just a handful,
handful,
it goes eat them.
I was like,
okay,
I want to have an experience.
You got to eat him on an empty stomach.
I hadn't eaten.
Of course.
That's really good.
And we're climbing man.
And I just started literally just hallucinating.
I,
you're better off that you didn't eat anything.
If he had eaten it something you'd probably throw the problem.
I took a shower one time,
I wouldn't get out of the shower.
Patty was banging on the door and I was like,
I'll be there.
I'm trying to figure something out.
And then,
nope.
It's hard to explain.
But I believe I kept seeing my profile and the first thing I was like,
as I kept saying,
oh I fuck,
I wish I was barrel chested.
I'm not barrel chested.
My grandfather's barrel chested.
I know I have a sunken chest.
This is horse shit.
And I was,
I was like,
that's a terrible profile.
So then I resolved,
resolved.
I was in the shower to just spend the entire summer on a bench press.
I was going to hire a coach,
just a bench,
which that never happened.
And then I came out of the shower and then I had this experience of somebody
standing like watching me and judging me.
And I felt like it was the devil telling me that I was a phony.
So I was like,
oh,
I'm a phony.
I'm a skinny phony.
He was the devil.
I don't fucking know.
I just felt I saw this.
That just felt like that's what it was like.
It was just the truth and so me and I was so raw.
I came out one thing,
God maybe,
maybe or was it just felt like the devil because he didn't want to admit the
truth.
Exactly.
That's what the,
that's what the bank that is bro.
I can always tell people,
you can just see,
it's so interesting to watch how people,
like I was thinking about this the other day,
how people basically as adult like I would call it to adulthood and what they
call maturity is the slow acceptance of what you will never be.
That's kind of what it is.
So what happens is you so much things.
I was like,
you see little girls dressed like princesses,
right?
And,
and that's their ideal.
They grow up with these ideas.
We still,
we stick these ideals and children.
Like you're going to marry a prince and he's going to be pimped prince charming
and that shit gets whittled away.
You start settling for simulation and simulation.
It.
Basically your life becomes,
I'll take what I can get until finally you're dating some guy with hair on his
ears and a potbelly,
well,
at least he pays a fucking bills,
which is when I had to get them.
By the way,
I like to get them when they're just going through a divorce,
had their heartbroken to 300 times.
They're 40 they work out way too much.
That anger and frustration is combined into this fucking wood creates like a
freaky that I can really work with.
Hotel 39 year old.
Crazy wall.
Yes.
Look at my ass.
I'd work out all the time.
That's house.
Yeah.
I like them old,
not even old,
old.
That's young for me.
So when you're coming down the hill,
you're totally naked.
You're high as a kite on mushrooms.
Do whatever.
Any point.
Realize like you starting to sober up at any point in time,
like what's what's happening as you're sobering up,
what,
what was happening?
As I was sobering up and because I'm such a freak because I had read a lot about
how when you can be on a mountain in the summer or a winter storm can brew up,
right.
They can keep up,
you can get caught in hail storms,
freeze to death actually sometimes,
you know.
And so,
uh,
I was like,
I was like I got to get the phone and I'd read about k two and I don't know if
you've ever read about climbing k two.
It's one thing to climb Mount Everest.
It's quite another thing to can't climb.
K Two I believe there's only one side of k two one can climb.
And for a while I believe in,
you can check this on factcheck one in four people,
uh,
wouldn't make it,
on k two people died all the time because before people would make it like
didn't survive.
Can you do fact check?
Cause I believe that was the case for quite awhile.
She's crashed.
And so what happened was it was the holy grail of mountain still is cause uh,
cause um,
what happens is storms whip up really fucking fast.
Like really fast and a,
and you die.
Yeah.
So,
so what happened was I,
um,
I started thinking of storm might whip up and I suck in the cold.
Whoa.
What does it say on fact check?
Um,
it's just talking about there was a,
there's been a bunch of disasters up there.
Oh,
a lot of people have died on Kaytoo.
Yeah.
You don't climb k,
two very few people.
Client when you meet a mountain climber and they said,
I got to the top of k two.
That dude is on the all star team.
Wow.
That's a very rare dude.
And you have to go through Pakistan,
I think on the Pakistan side.
Yeah.
No bodies and you pass bodies all the time.
Okay.